well it's good to be with all you today
hang on a second I'm gonna grab me a
beer very casually say the jello
happened to catch that big sporting
match over the weekend I tell you what
when when the star player got that score
at the end of the game I just about went
crazy I jumped up and I started slapping
hands with all of my ethnically diverse
friends and we all said yes go sports
and it was just it was Jenny way I'm
just shooting the breeze I guess I
confess I'm a bit jazz today by that
Elizabeth Warren video I don't know if
you saw it but Elizabeth Warren is
trying to be relatable to the common man
you know and and so she did an insta jet
Internet video where she stopped at the
beginning of the video to drink a beer
and you know she made sure to film
herself drinking a beer so that everyone
would see that Elizabeth Warren drinks
beers and man it was the most relatable
thing you will ever see in fact I was at
the bar when I heard about it this young
fellow sitting next to me he pulls out
his cellular telephone and he says hey
everybody check out this video clip
Elizabeth Warren is just like us and I
looked at it and sure enough she's there
throwing back in old brewski as the kids
like to say so look I'll just say this
okay at the beginning I'm a conservative
and that's no secret but but I've got to
admit to any Democrat who was listening
Elizabeth Warren is a dynamic politician
she is an absolute star frankly as a
conservative I am terrible I'm petrified
at the prospect of her running for
president in 2020 it just it terrifies
me because nobody can connect with the
average American like Senator Warren we
have never seen a political figure who
resonates especially with the young the
way that Warren does you know I forgot
to mention my
favorite part of that video is the best
part is when she brings her husband into
the shot and she actually says to her
husband thank you for being here and
then Pat's him on the back to her she
says that to her own husband in their
own kitchen now if that does not qualify
as natural human dialog between two
married people then I don't know what
does in fact it reminds me of my own
wife who every morning before I leave
for work she always shakes my hand and
says please please stay in touch it's
just that's the way right like that's
the way married people talk to each
other we talk to each other like like we
are you know you a wife talks to her
husband like she's a game show host
greeting a you know a contestant like
pate Pat Sajak when he's interviewing
the contestants during wheel of fortune
that's just that's how we talk to each
other right it's totally normal if
Warren gets the nomination I I'm gonna
have to switch political teams this is
just my confession right now okay and
I'm not alone in that Elizabeth Warren
is just that magnetic think about it any
old politician can try to earn points
with minorities by claiming to be
partially a minority but who besides
Warren would have the tenacity and the
courage to take a DNA test and prove
that they are actually a tenth of a
tenth of 1% Native American or maybe
Mexican or something in that general
ethnic vicinity I mean good luck winning
even one minority vote if Elizabeth
Warren is your opponent okay because
rest assured that minorities do not feel
at all degraded or insulted or demeaned
when you try to earn their support by
taking a DNA test I
and I know that because my great uncles
nieces best friends friend was married
to someone from the Pacific Islands so
you know I'm basically Hawaiian so I can
I think I can speak to these kinds of
things
this woman is formidable that's all I'm
saying she scares me even more than 1/3
Hillary Clinton term scares me speaking
of which I thought Hillary Clinton was
the most charismatic and genuine
politician in American history but then
along comes Elizabeth Warren and it's
look please Democrats don't nominate her
ok and definitely don't put Warren and
Clinton on a ticket together because
then you'll win all the votes and you're
not gonna leave any votes for anyone
else and it's just not fair so have
mercy on us okay and please don't
nominate Cory Booker either or or or
Bernie Sanders the elderly white
socialists who just bought his third
house a $600,000 vacation home
he could win 70 million votes easy so
don't nominate any of these people
Democrats you would crush us and it and
I think it should be a fair fight so
give us a chance at least be good sports
about it that's all I'm saying okay take
off my sarcasm head now yes I did just
mime taking off an actual invisible
sarcasm an but we'll just move past that
on a more serious note the daily wire
reports about this a few days ago I
don't know if you saw this this this
report of the daily wire about an awful
propaganda video that was released late
last week and it features a radical
feminist who's also the the founder of
shout your abortion the move the shout
your abortion movement where women are
encouraged to go and brag about their
abortions and this woman her name is
Amelia but now I found out how to
pronounce the last name let's just say
let's just call her Bono
maybe it's bono Amelia bono extolling
the wonders of abortion to a group of
children bono sits with a series of
visibly uncomfortable kids and she
boasts to them about the time when she
decided to kill her child it really is
just a chilling video in so many
respects and she's she's sitting there
you know talking to these kids actually
describing the quote procedure in this
overly childish and anti scientific
language awkwardly kind of papering over
the violent reality of what she
actually discussing and this by the way
is the same childish language that
pro-abortion people use no matter who
they're talking to when they're talking
to adults they used this same kind of
language so it's not like she toned it
down for kids this is just how they talk
about it
she says that when she's asked what
abortion is like or what it involves
she says that abortion is sucking out
the pregnancy with a quote straw that's
how she describes it and she says that
it's it's important that women have this
right because she should not be forced
to create life is how she phrases it
which of course is a total misnomer
because by the time you're having the
abortion the life has already been
created if the life had not been created
yet then there'd be no reason for the
abortion abortion is specifically
designed to kill a living thing if
there's no living thing to create or to
kill then there's no need for an
abortion but if there is a living thing
to kill then that means that the living
thing has already been created
thus abortion does not prevent the
creation of new life it destroys life
that has already been created there is I
think a very that might seem
grammatically very similar but in
actuality those are vastly different
things so she she's sitting there she's
talking these kids she admits to the
children that she chose to have sex with
without contraception that's how she got
pregnant before she got the abortion and
yes she is sitting there talking to
apparently middle school boys about why
she had sex without a condom so this is
this is the sexual harassment of
children along with with everything else
but of the of the kids that she's
talking about one rather Stute young man
speculates that maybe she was being
reckless
that maybe her behavior is reckless and
this is this was her response to the
charge of being reckless this is what
she says I'm gonna read it verbatim
she says I
mean I don't I wouldn't really say that
I was being reckless mistakes happen and
and sometimes you just don't do that in
the moment you know what I mean and the
boy says I don't know which is the most
apt response he put he could have
possibly come up with but here's the
most revealing part of the of the
segment she attempts to compare abortion
to a more legitimate kind of medical
procedure and this is what she says she
says it was it was like a crappy dentist
appointment or something it was just
like ah this is like a body thing that's
kind of uncomfortable but then it was
over and I felt like really just
grateful that I wasn't pregnant anymore
let's let's leave aside the fact that
this video features an adult talking to
children yet somehow the latter group is
by far the most eloquent and a
well-spoken we'll leave that aside the
interesting thing is that she wants the
kids and the rest of society to see
abortion as nothing more than a crappy
dentist appointment as how she puts it
yet
you'll notice something she created a
shout your abortion campaign she did not
create a shout your dental procedure
campaign and I'm I don't know this for
effect but I'm guessing that she's never
filmed herself explaining root canals to
12 year olds so abortion is like a
dentist appointment she claims but she
only goes around frantically trying to
justify abortions and not dentist
appointments why is that well I think
the simplest explanation is probably the
right one here feminists brag about
their abortions and not their dental
procedures because abortion is and they
know it
nothing at all like a dental procedure
they know it for all their rhetoric for
all the euphemistic language the
papering over the you know the
obfuscation they know deep down that
abortion is different it is a different
kind of thing abortion is serious it is
violent it's dirty
it's shameful they all know this it
doesn't really need to be explained to
them that's why they're constantly
trying to explain the opposite because
they know the truth and when they go
around shouting their abortion to us or
to kids they're really shouting their
abortions to themselves that's the point
of these shout your abortion movement so
if you were to watch this video you
could in your mind replace those
children with mirrors and I think you'd
get a better idea of the of the
psychology that's at play here
these you know she is talking to herself
and these kids are just props they're
sounding boards and they're meant to sit
there silently so that this woman can
bounce her own thoughts back to herself
and that's why that's why you'll find
that pro-abortion left us they like to
use kids for these kinds of things
number one because kids are malleable
and they're trying to brainwash them but
also because kids generally are just
gonna sit there and listen to whatever
you're saying and accept it and they
don't want to be challenged that's what
they want they just want a silent human
to sit there and listen to them talk to
themselves but as she's trying to
convince herself you noticed that she's
not convincing herself she isn't fooling
herself and she isn't fooling us and
she's barely even fooling the kids
that's how pathetic this all really is
so it's I think there's a generally
reliable rule here okay the rule is that
if you are offering unsolicited
justifications for a personal choice to
people who did not ask for those
justifications that means that you are
very far from comfortable with that with
that choice if you're going around
explaining to everyone why you did a
certain thing that means that you feel
guilty or uncomfortable with having done
that thing
I mean think about it in your own life
even if you've never gotten an abortion
hopefully anytime that you've done
something or made a choice and then you
feel the need to bring it up to people
and kind of like work talk through your
own reasoning for doing the thing
anytime you've done this because you
know you're not actually comfortable
with the choice that you made and you're
talking to yourself and you're also
hoping that they will agree with you to
make you feel to reinforce you and your
rationalizations this is why by the way
this is why feminists are always going
around explaining justifying their
abortions but you don't find parents
going around justifying their decision
to have kids have you noticed that now
parents will talk about parenting
parents will complain about parenting or
they might proclaim the joys of
parenting but they aren't gonna
constantly defend the fact that they had
kids in the first place and that's
because they know it was the right
choice they don't need to convince
themselves they don't need to convince
you and even when parenting is a
challenge it's still kind of fits it
makes sense it is it's it's um it is a
completion you know it's it brings
wholeness to their life and so that
makes the rightness of their decision to
have kids
that makes it self evident so they don't
need to explain it except in very rare
cases parents don't live in regret
because of having kids and thus they
don't feel the need to justify the fact
that they have kids to anyone now the
opposite is true of abortion and and and
that by the way I think is one of the
the central truths about abortion that
needs to be communicated to women that
abortion is like suicide a perm
solution to a temporary problem so a
woman who you know who decides to have
an abortion or a woman who's pregnant
she might feel she might feel
overwhelmed scared anxiety ridden about
about having a child she might feel like
it's gonna interfere with her life but
the chances are very high that when she
actually has the child she will very
very quickly start to feel differently
about the situation it's still gonna be
challenging to be a parent there's no
question about that
but very quickly she'll find that
whereas before she was unable to imagine
life with a child now she's unable to
imagine life without her child and
that's in and here's the thing about it
if a woman decides to have a child and
it is one of those rare cases where she
finds that it's not working she finds
that she really she can't care for the
child or whatever the case may be then
there's always adoption that option is
still a bit available but if you choose
death if you choose abortion if you
choose death then you're stuck with that
choice forever no matter no matter the
regret that you might feel afterwards
that is a permanent choice it is a
choice that cannot be undone it's a
choice that offers no additional roads
it's a dead end well it's a literal dead
end you make that choice and then that's
it whereas if you choose life then there
are many different choices that spring
from that choice as a parent you can go
in many different directions you can
raise your child in many different ways
you can make many different kinds of
choices for your family or there are
there are some parents who do end up
putting their kids up for adoption so
that that also is a choice that you can
make so all these choices are still
there there is this whole tree of
choices all these different
branches sprouting whereas with abortion
it is just it's at you chop the tree
down and you burn it and that's it and
that's why abortion leaves you feeling
incomplete empty disjointed it just
doesn't feel right it becomes this thing
that you constantly need to explain to
yourself which is why when you're when
you're listening to one of these
abortion advocates you could really
remove all the exclamation points from
their declarative sentences and replace
them with question marks and I think
then you get a better idea so when when
this woman or someone else is shouting
abortion is good abortion is right I'm
happy about my abortion what they really
mean is abortion is good abortion is
right I'm happy about my abortion and
then they reassure themselves yes yes
yes of course I'm happy
but they don't believe their own answer
so they just shout even louder hoping to
drown out that thought in the back of
their head that thought that tells them
that this is all a lie and they've done
something terrible and permanent and
they can't undo it that's the reality
that's why these shout your abortion
campaigns exist all right one other
thing I wanted to talk about briefly
alexandria occasion cortez let's talk
about her for a minute
unfortunately a video of the new
congresswoman went viral yesterday
online and it appears that the video was
first found and posted by a right-wing
account on twitter in an effort to mock
cortez about the mocking attempt
backfires big time because the video all
the video shows is his cortez apparently
in college or maybe high school dancing
on a rooftop with some of her friends
and she's you know not a bad dancer and
it seems like she's having a good time
it's kind of a fun silly video that she
which was a teenager the kind of video
that only an absolute maniac would get
angry about and the video makes her seem
more relatable more likeable it's the
kind of thing that you'd expect her camp
to find and post not her enemies and and
maybe her camp didn't put it out there
hoping to bait a few idiot right-wingers
and and and they were successful in
doing it I don't know but I emphasize a
few here because I saw in addition to
the account that posted the video
originally I only saw a few
conservatives on social media trying to
attack Cortez over the footage the vast
majority of people on the left and right
we're defending her they were saying the
video is fine it's a fun video whatever
so it's not true as the media is
reporting today that conservatives in
general were angry about her dancing or
mocking her for it
a few were just a few from what I can
tell only a few however it is true that
conservatives in general not all but
many have been maybe not with this video
but they have been rather obsessed with
Alexandria occasional Cortes over the
past year or so they have jumped on many
opportunities to mock her they have been
fixated on her they've been talking
about her even more often than liberals
do and I've made this point before
because foolish people on either side of
the aisle they tend to make stars out of
people on the opposing side so liberal
liberals made a star out of Donald Trump
by their obsession with him if the media
and liberals in general weren't so
obsessed with Donald Trump during the
campaign especially during the primary
then Donald Trump probably would not be
President today but right-wingers
contend to do the same kind of thing
they were obsessed with David hog and
now they're obsessed with Cortes and in
that obsession they helped both of those
people to achieve levels of fame and
notoriety that
otherwise would would not have achieved
especially with Cortez now I know you
might say well but she's a socialist and
she's dangerous she's and she's in a
position of power now so we we have to
engage with her ideas we can't ignore
her well okay but two things here number
one she's one of 435 members of the
House of Representatives she has very
very little actual individual power and
and whatever power she has in her own
district well it's a liberal district it
would have been a Democrat there anyway
she doesn't have anymore
actual legal real power than any of the
other 435 and none of them individually
have much power at all the power that
she has is in her popularity in her fame
in her influence on the culture but you
only increase that power by increasing
her popularity and fame when you talk
about her so the best thing that the
right could have done with this woman
from the very beginning
is just ignore her number two yeah we
should engage socialist ideas we need to
be able to do that but but let's be
honest about this conservatives haven't
really been engaging her ideas per se
you know some of them have but for the
most part that's not what's happening
here we have just been relentlessly
mocking her as a person and I've done it
to on occasion not nearly as often as a
lot of other people but I mean she
didn't know the branches of governments
how can you not mock that it's just it's
impossible not to but when I mocked that
thing I knew that I was just preaching
to the choir I wasn't doing anything
fruitful or helpful really I was just
laughing because it was funny and I
couldn't help myself
generally though the personal mockery of
this woman is not in effective strategy
as I said yeah when someone doesn't know
the branches of government and they're
in the government I mean you have to
make fun of that what else are you gonna
do
but in general this obsession just it
has it has it has not worked out for
four Republicans for the right it
obviously has not worked to decrease her
popularity it has done the opposite why
is that well I think because well for
one thing people on the other side are
just gonna coalesce even more around
their guy or their girl when they
perceive that unfair personal attacks
are being launched at them but more to
the point here like it or not
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is likable
okay now you might not like her you
might disagree with her which by the way
those two things don't need to go hand
in hand not liking her and disagreeing
with her but you know and I disagree
with her certainly um but she is likable
objectively speaking she is she just is
she comes across like a relatively
normal 25 year old woman or 29 year old
woman who is really super stoked to be
in Congress and it all seems pretty
genuine and pretty human and people are
attracted to that they they are so when
you're dealing with an opponent who is
likable you can't go scorched earth
against them because if you come off
like a bully or like a jealous nerd
which is how I think Republicans often
come off when it comes to to this woman
not even like bullies but even worse
than that they come off like they're
like jealous nerds in high school and
when you do that you're only going to
make them more likeable so even putting
the ethics and the morality of it aside
political strategy wise heaping mockery
and scorn on a likeable person is bad
strategy it's very bad you make them
more likeable and yourself less when you
do that this is a lesson that that
Donald Trump needs to learn before 2020
because he's had enormous success going
scorched-earth against opponents who
were all
ready fairly unlikable or extremely
unlikable Clinton obviously is a prime
example Clinton is a very unlikable
person so it really didn't matter what
Donald Trump said about her he could say
whatever he wanted and even in the
primaries
I mean Jeb Bush Ted Cruz Kasich these
guys are not what you would call
extremely relatable or likable
politicians I supported Cruz I still do
but he's you you're fooling yourself if
you call him likable he's not he's not a
likable guy
so Trump just ripped them to pieces and
it worked because he was kind of
highlighting the unlikable aspects of
their person is part of the the
nicknames and stuff that he doesn't
that's one of the reasons why that was
effective is because he's he's homing in
on the most unlikable parts of them and
highlighting and that's and that's the
point but if he faces someone like like
O'Rourke
in 2020 a guy who however you feel about
him is certainly likable and if he tries
to treat beto like he treated Clinton or
Cruz it will absolutely backfire look at
what Republicans did in the campaign
against you know in the campaign in
Texas the one that better almost won
they posted pictures what Republicans
are they they posted pictures of of
o'rourke from his punk rock days in the
90s and they mocked him for it and then
what happened it backfired because the
pictures just made him look cooler and
more likable
the people looked at that I said they
said oh he was in a band awesome that's
the thing normal people think that bands
are cool it's it's cool if you were in a
band when you were when you were younger
that that's how normal people react to
that a normal person isn't going to say
oh you were in a band when you were
younger dork that's no that's that's not
what normal people do normal people
think oh that's cool I mean I'd like to
get a beer with that guy and talk about
his experience in a punk rock band he
probably has some stories to tell it's
probably pretty interesting that's what
normal people think
again it only makes him more likable and
you less the same thing happens on the
other side the new congressman Dan
Crenshaw very likable guy and that's why
think about this SNL they make they mock
Republicans all the time
in ways that are just vicious I mean
think about all the the mocking of
Donald Trump Alec Baldwin's caricature
of Trump is is mean and mean-spirited
and vicious and they do that the
Republicans all the time yet they mocked
Crenshaw just one kind of throwaway line
and the next week they had to have him
on they had to have him on the show to
apologize to him in person and why is
that well of course he's a veteran and
they were and the the joke that they
made was horrible so that obviously is
part of it but also the guy is likable
and relatable so people just like him he
seems like a decent guy and so when you
make fun of him people say well what are
you doing back off what did that guy
ever do to you
nikki Haley I think is another one
that's also in this campaign a naturally
likable politician you know who else I
would put in this category that may
surprise you Mike Pence
now pence is likable in a different kind
of way I'm not sure if he comes off as
relatable necessarily and he definitely
doesn't come off as cool but he does
come off he seems like a decent friendly
mr. Rogers kind of guy and I mean that
would no disrespect to mr. Rogers who
was a decent friendly good guy right and
now whether or not he actually is those
things I don't know I don't know him
personally but that's how he comes
across that's how it seems
and so leftist they've made fools of
themselves over the last few years when
they're constantly mocking Mike Pence
they come off looking like lunatics and
jerks and he comes off looking like a
decent guy who isn't going to get down
in the mud with the pigs think about it
the left has taken how many shots at
Mike Pence over the last two years to
three years and how many of those shots
have Lane
how many of them have failed the
backfire that's because he seems decent
likable
maybe decent in his case is a better
word than likable but whatever either
way mockery is not effective against
likeable and/or decent seeming opponents
now of course there aren't very many of
those types in politics today and most
are so viscerally unlikable that it's
comical like Warren you can make fun of
Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren all you want
because she just she like Clinton it's
just it's it's you you listen to her
talk for five seconds and you don't like
her doesn't matter Latics aside you just
don't like her that's how she comes
across now if we could have a different
conversation someday about why it is
that those types of people seem to
always win campaigns but that's how it
is and if you're facing somebody if
you're dealing with someone like that
Elizabeth Warren with her with her beer
drinking video yeah make fun of that all
day it's hilarious
she's unlikable it's an unlikable thing
that she did it's cynical and just weird
and disingenuous and fine Hiep mockery
on that that's what it deserves but
somebody like Alexandria okay isn't
Cortez it's just not working so I think
if you're an opponent of hers if you
don't like her best strategy is mostly
to ignore her and let her do her thing
and when she comes out with a proposal
or with ideas or with legislation or
whatever that's that's bad then you
engage with the legislation you engage
with the ideas and you have that
argument on an intellectual level that's
the best way to engage with people in
general but strategy wise it's really
the only way to engage with likeable
people
all right we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching have a great
weekend I'll talk to you next week
Godspeed